Kip how about that stay trashy tour low
ticket alert moving some picky wikis
gang listen here's the turkey we've been
all over the country we're coming again
it's a good time stand-up comedy play
little ayg with the crowd come and hang
yeah guys this is just the first leg in
March we're starting Baltimore Maryland
Virginia Beach Virginia Richmond
Virginia Oklahoma City Dallas Texas
Houston Texas Austin Texas then in April
we're doing New Haven Connecticut
Burlington Vermont then in May we're
doing Tampa Dania Beach Florida Raleigh
North Carolina then in June we're doing
Cleveland and Columbus we're adding more
cities as tickets are going quick some
are about to sell out if they're not
already sold out so don't snooze on us
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah that little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find that it's a group
to be classy yeah such as just a big old
piece of trash trash I'm your host Dave
trolley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at antuti's basement
she's out at the Acme stealing dinner
okay so talk about sous vide you don't
want to know where she keeps the fillets
okay all right my co-host is coming at
you from across the table it's a goddamn
Family episode ladies and gentlemen just
the boys just the girls just the bozos
and just the homies he is the CEO of are
you garbage he's an international
businessman he is not to be trifled with
in the boardroom the bedroom or the
bathroom
thanks it's KJ that ain't no cheerleader
in there Kevin James Ryan what up gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate review so you're so
perfect make sure you rate review
subscribe on iTunes fall video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
cooking
I mean that thing is on that thing's
[__] smoking methods I love it I
don't know what counter must be broke
over there you go uh guys when you sign
up for patreon uh you get the uh uh a
crap ton uh I can't curse in the first
minute you get a crap ton of content I'm
talking like a maybe two three bajillion
hours we got episodes of hard feelings
we got bonus episodes ayg we got the
Disney vids come we got everything
cooking over there check it out real
jive turkey over there on that patreon
yeah that's not a curse nope how about a
nice quick shout out to our producer X
Jordan Air the magic man makes this all
look good works those ones Works those
twos crosses those t's dots those eyes
got a fresh pack of crayons back there
give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen everybody what up dude what up
T Bayern yo cute insults are the best
yeah like this mother sniffing Bumble
butt
shout out to him dude sounds like a
bunch of hoos yeah yeah dude what was it
a Wiggy muffins uh elf sniggle Puffs
something like that I don't know if you
do it you're gonna clean it up I tell
you that much you know what they're
really talking about loose broads
the fresh pack of crayons made me fresh
fish packing crayons made me think ah
what was your uh what was your crowning
achievement as a child for school
projects what was the best thing you
ever made I made a diorama were they
called let me take it easy no where were
they were the shoe box in the other on
like The Shoe Box big Indian dinner huh
right diarrhea I don't know
that's where you went with it okay uh
like The Shoe Box inside the shoebox lid
inside the shoe box and you create the
little environment for the animals or
whatever of course
um I think one of those
no I should say it's just horse stables
uh I remember the one time I had to make
an atom this is nibbles he's a mob horse
big needle going into it uh I had to
make an atom and I really accomplished
what's an atom an atom like Adam and Eve
no an atom that oh an atom yeah what am
I saying you said Adam and Adam Adam
you didn't say atom are you listen you
just said Adam
you just said no there's different Adam
Adam Adam Adam Adam
you're not saying at home yeah I
understand I'm putting I'm saying it
properly Adam is Adam Adam
you're saying the same word when you say
yeah I'm telling you you are stop I
might not say words right but I got
eight headphones on and I hear exactly
what you're saying ready you have to
meet my friend Adam
and then he's made of atoms you didn't
say that when you said it the first time
you're just yes I did you also said on
the exact same no I didn't do yes you
did at
um that's not what you're saying that's
not what you said the first time Adam
and Adam that's oh sure that's not what
you did when you said it's Adam you go
it's not Adam it's Adam I think you're
lying uh Toby the guy on the charger
that wants it too just agreed with me
Toby I do cross the t's and Dot the eyes
and you did not have a t in that Adam
that was a d you know everything about
electrons though tell you that that was
an uppercase d an atom yeah uh and we
bought this thing for like a wreath or
something tennis balls and golf balls
that's what everybody was doing but I I
cut why I wanted and my dad had my dad
weld it and he was so mad dude I waited
till the night before we had to we had
to go I was like yeah you gotta welcome
to acetylene out or whatever yeah he had
to go the acetylene we gotta drive to
the [__] office to get his uh
soldering machine or like soldering Tank
come back to the house do it I remember
he was smoking to see because he was
[__] soldering it back together oh it
stunk man he was so mad drop that [__] I
made it eight o'clock on a Wednesday he
was upset man they hated that [__] yeah
getting drugged to Michael's at like 7
30 on a Wednesday
um no shot at getting a pack of candy
then I'll tell you that we also had to
make an egg launcher at one point
and it was like simple machines you know
what I mean like a pulley a lever and a
fulcrum was that the other one yeah uh
and this one had to be done with simple
machines to make who could launch the
egg the furthest ninth grade probably
eighth grade and simple machine for a
simple boy yeah no I had my step honor
student huh what were you doing not
doing I was I wasn't doing potato guns
in high school he was getting straight
A's of throwing rocks from trains yeah
crushing Pennies on the train tracks
that's what you were doing
break a window at the Old Johnson Place
no we did uh my my crowning achievement
was uh graduation day or the last day of
schooling must have been a good career
graduation day no one's doing work
congratulations I'm still trying to play
catch-up
eighth grade we threw eggs off the
building that's your crowning
achievement in listen listen don't
jumpstarter no that's not a project we
threw it was like well we didn't launch
eggs and there I am on the roof throwing
eggs no we had to make a parachute for
an egg and the Egg couldn't crack you
had to have something that could get it
down there safely that's very close to
my project no we weren't shooting them
plus I hard-boiled
I'm like we launching eggs you're like
no we were making them land safely did
you really slam that thing you got a
jack slam that thing on the ground
wasn't gonna break yours were scrambled
I'm gonna get too high and dry will you
make an omelette gun oh
God mine's a western
if you're not gonna eat your fries I'll
have them you're not gonna eat your
taters nah I did a regular one but that
was that was my that was my best thing I
can't congratulation day are you in a
slow class that's what you're doing as a
senior in high school oh I said eighth
grade oh eighth grade the last day of
school at eighth grade in this you know
when the summer started you had this big
thing and the teachers went up there and
they would throw them off and every the
whole school gathered around I think the
news was there that probably was a slow
day slow kid drops egg but I used
um I want to say it was like the GI Joe
I had I had like a pretty solid
parachute and it floated right down man
it was like D-Day it's fantastic that
was that was the best hit the dlz and
then the next year in high school in
wood shop we broke out the architecture
stuff the the foam strips and you had
you made a house you didn't have to make
a house no I like the foam board you
mean yeah no we'd have to make a house
we mine was rough I made a cigar box and
I kept my Chiba in
had a little drawer for my papers and
all uh yeah we made a cigar box I think
we had to make a car like uh
like out of a single you know little
soapbox race car yeah it's probably
eighth grade ninth grade probably that
was Junior High I was eighth grade
probably the kids that were really good
at that yikes yeah those are the things
you wanted to be bad at yeah to a degree
won't get over there making a shank
getting ready you're getting ready for
the yard
yeah nah uh
uh but I hate it yeah I never really did
well in anything the papers whatever
that was just get by if it had to be
eight pages you know you you fidget to
be eight pages the projects were all
right I did kind of enjoy that I mean
make it a little more interesting if
you're [__] launching exit from the
50-yard line that ain't bad yeah uh my
stepdad did that we spent way too much
like he was just like wait I mean he
made it his price fully automatically
that thing people were like what the
[__] shoots a dozen eggs a minute we
ended up losing too [__] I'll break
uh I wanted to ask you this too because
I do this a lot
um you know I personify things is it
trash to say goodbye to places when you
leave them like goodbye house
is that weird
yeah like if you leave a place thank you
goodbye house I think so is that what
you do yeah I always say goodbye say
goodbye to your apartment
if I'm leaving for a while I do
well yeah I know or if like in fact we
stayed in Airbnb and I leave the Airbnb
in my head I'll be like buy Airbnb thank
you for everything
uh is that weird that's very weird yeah
that's crazy
and that's stuff you do with like we
just put sunglasses on that stuff you do
with your nieces and nephews like say
bye to the whatever that's weird to me
yeah but I don't know you're a weird guy
I don't know what to tell you what about
the car does your car have a full
personality and all that stuff no we've
talked about this it doesn't no huh it's
just a car it just gets me from point A
to point B I I don't have a name for it
or anything all right
uh yeah no I don't say uh no I don't say
bye to say bye to the apartment no by
the building
no no people people are gonna think
there's something wrong with you walking
down yeah goodbye elevator see you later
mailbox
goodbye pizza place see you at lunch not
those things okay well I mean where do
you draw the line I don't know a place
that you stayed at
all right yeah that's weird to me I
don't know if it's trashy that's
full-blown Toby that's full-blown
psychotic if you ask me help me out here
I don't wanna if I feel like if I do I'd
be enabling crazy behavior she's like oh
yeah everybody's saying for an example
when we left the Airbnb in Disney you
didn't say goodbye bye house no really I
said hello New York yeah I said bye
Orlando I ain't never coming back
um that's yeah no that's weird yeah I
don't know what to tell you that's uh I
should probably talk to a professional
or something to clear that up real
estate agent what do you think is going
to happen if you don't say bye do you
think it's rude no like they're gonna be
like that Airbnb is going to be mad at
you and chase you down the block you
didn't say bye to me it's not a fear you
ruined my toilet
you do that to my toilet you don't even
say bye to me kind of kind of stood not
are you Daryl it ah no I don't know what
it is I guess it's personification okay
I make everything
alive sure does that that makes sense
no I mean no it doesn't make sense I
guess in the the logic kind of I I'll
live in this
childish world with you that's crazy
yeah all right okay all right uh
welcome back to am I a psychopath ladies
and gentlemen
saying goodbye to the Airbnb or is it a
fake house there's a fake house in
Orlando yeah it wasn't a fake house it
was a real house it was four walls his
name was Gary
and he was a nice sweet boy he was a
gentle lover and cooked me eggs in the
morning that I quickly threw off the
roof he was going through a bad divorce
if you must know it yeah he has two kids
from a previous marriage give the guy a
break he's got two sheds from a previous
marriage
he's got an in-law suite that won't stop
hounding him
oh man but gang it's a gosh darn Family
episode sign up for that patreon over
there where I'll answer your garbage
question on here and I gotta let you
know the homies over here on patreon
come with some real Barn burners real
humdingers they do they know what
they're doing they're real trash baby
they're top-notch trash and you gotta
love them uh all right this one's from
rwm ever take medication with a dipping
sauce
hahaha
no but um I don't think that would work
per se since the honey mustard Percocets
yeah unless it's got a bad taste or
something I usually raw dog them we've
talked about that yeah usually raw dog
them but what I will do
um little maple syrup no I'll make them
stickier
I'll name each pill and then build a
little house that they live in and I
don't like eating my friends take them
with Cheetos ah I gotta put peanut
butter on it like I'm a dog get me to
eat a piece of cheese hold your nose I
was always jealous of that that the dog
got a piece of cheese with his pills
sure my dad would just stand over top me
swallow it swallow it because I was
really bad with that like a real calm
guy and he asked first got dressed as
well love you Pop
um
I was really scared to uh
to take pills when I was a kid I
couldn't swallow them I'd all changed in
college I started snorting them
doctors said I could snort these
no but I remember that when they were
pre-basing diamonds happening great I
remember when they were trying to break
me of the Children's Tylenol which I
loved sure uh it took take the regular
red stuff yeah they were the red ones
wait no the red oh you were taking
children Tylenol licking a red bottle
yeah no no we had little Children's
Tylenol that were chewable and they
weren't too bad they weren't it wasn't a
lutons but it was okay oh I remember
that I remember the phase into adult
pills was like it was scary what I'm
gonna get a job after this what are we
doing it's this real man [__] we're
talking what are you giving me Etc
I know back problems
give me the juice take those water pills
and stick them up your ass I hated uh
that red uh red tile and all if you had
a fever that's what like this the Sip
like out of the man you might as well
been giving me plutonium I [__] hated
that guy Chase it with a [__] shot of
Sprite
[Laughter]
take the edge off make two more make
this into a snake bite yeah
um I didn't mind that stuff I actually
liked it there was there was a lot of
cough medicine that I like I love
Diamond tap is fantastic the great dime
attack dude I remember even at an early
age obviously as a fat little wee wee
Lads there's still a chubster today uh
but I'm working on it
um
it would curb my appetite and after like
four days I was I remember feeling I was
I wasn't I just wasn't hungry but I
remember feeling trimmed what are you a
divorced woman
taking dexa trim
pills do you remember texting true I
mean I had the little pills inside that
blew my mind a little tiny pellets
inside oh my father was just crank for
divorces yeah it's just meth it's just
speed dude right
[Laughter]
they're [__] all over the road holy
[__] I remember that stuff would make an
appearance here and there not with me uh
but just like it would be around or
someone would be taking it or whatever
um I no but the die I remember after a
couple of days being tight all right
tightening up lose a couple water weight
skip a skip a Burger King or whatever
and I'd be time ever being tight and I
remember being like oh dude you could
just take a shot of this every morning
you'd be you'd be trimming no time
beating off the ladies with a stick
like an old Diamond tip restaurant over
there
stop but the regular pills man that was
really yeah yeah I remember one time
when Advil came on the scene I was like
Eminem No I remember I suck on them
trying to take an Advil yeah and I was
like and I I wouldn't I'm like I'll just
suck on it and my mom's like you can't
do that I remember yelling at me I'm
like what it'll get into my bot like
it'll go I if I suck on a piece of candy
that goes into my stomach you know how
bad they taste once you get through that
candy I never made it I remember
spitting it out on the floor because the
way they got me to take the pills is uh
they would take the regular Tylenol and
they would put it between two spoons and
they would crush it and they would add a
little water to it and make me take it
and it tasted like it's like Civil War
[Music]
Hills and making your own Elixir dude it
was brutal but the lime and my dad just
coming home from work one day when I was
sick and he was just [__] fed up with
it it'd been going on for like six
months I'd gotten sick like two or three
times and he was just so pissed and he
just sat there and he was like take the
[__] pill took it and once I got the
hang of it I just started doing a
recreation I can do like five six pills
at once and just knock them back but
what I was gonna say is what I do not
honey mustard but I'll keep aren't you a
big boy yeah right I can tie my own
shoes too
I don't say not really but I used to be
able to tie my own shoes Henry's doing
[__] was that
Henry's doing bills at an eighth grade
level a little my little Henry's already
snorting pills the name of Steve can't
even take him yet
does your son have his own straw you
legitimately said I can do five five at
a time yeah
he's something's going something's going
on a little construction next door
somebody's digging a way out over there
oh [__] it's gonna be a goddamn coal
miner
what year is it you guys got any Cobalt
in here
he went the wrong way buddy Kip's mint
mobile baby the mintiest of the mobiles
oh one of our faves over there uh-huh
gang if one of your big uh New Year's
resolutions was not to blow money and be
a jerk off okay do yourself a favor and
get over to Mint mobile you can order it
from home and you're saving tons of
money what is it 15 bucks a month yep
let's go and you know who owns that oh
at Ryan Reynolds
kids a dish and he just had a fourth kid
helped the kid out will you Jesus Christ
use a couple of bucks uh by going on on
by going online only mint mobile passes
those savings on to you yeah so you
choose no brick and mortar all plans
come with unlimited talk and text plus
high-speed data delivered on on the
nation's largest 5G networks use your
own phone with any mint Mobile plan and
switch easily in minutes with e Sim
there you go switch them in Mobile
premium Wireless serving started just 15
bucks a month like the big man said to
get your new Wireless plan for just 15 a
month and get the plan shipped to your
door for free go to mintmobile.com
garbage that's mintmobile.com garbage
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month atmobile.com garbage do it folks
can't be it's butcher box butcher box
butcher box who but your butcher box
butcher box yeah I got a fridge full of
meat yep bang I'll tell you what they
sent over the kitchen you forgot we were
doing an Android and I like it they sent
over to kitten caboodle dude I know I
got ribs coming out of the years I got
ground beef I got turkey I got free
range chicken no antibiotics grass-fed
grass finish free range the whole nine
yards man they do a real nice over there
and they take the guesswork out of it
they do I like when they just send it I
tell the bird figure it out whatever
they send it I don't care if it's turkey
or pigeon I know get something cooking
shout out guav I've had it really yeah
uh you know what they sent real quick
what's a side note they sent a pork loin
oh yeah dude that thing was banging yeah
slice that up I got a rack of ribs I
don't know it's like a brontosaurus or
something this thing's huge I had to get
a meat freezer for this thing don't even
fit in a regular freezer got him off the
Undertaker I'm giving out racks of ribs
like Bumpy Johnson
hahaha
dude they hook it up all right let's get
back on track here we were professionals
gosh darn it you enjoy a range of high
quality cuts at an amazing price plus
free shipping in continental US no
surprise feeds butcher boxes offering
our listeners one of their best deals
yet who knows what they want a hundred
percent clear cow 100 grass-fed chuck
roast and a whole organic chicken free
when you join and an additional 20 off
your box jeez sign up today at
butcherbox.com
ayg use the code ayg to get a hundred
percent grass-fed chuck roast and a
whole chicken free in your first box
plus 20 off that's butcherbox.com
ayg and use code ayg to get this special
deal on back to the gosh darn show back
to the show uh all right this one's from
Bruce this is something we used to oh no
I'm sorry it's not for music from
Cameron uh is it garbage to put a piece
of bread in a bag of cookies to keep
them softer for longer did you know that
rule that trick that's a real old uh
that's a poor Dirtbag trick so you bake
fresh cookies and then you take a
container whenever you put them in and
you put a piece of bread in there and
that absorbs the air first and that gets
crazy [__] hard after like a day and
the cookies stay soft mushy delicious
we used to do that with bacon what yeah
put a piece of bread in there with the
bacon to soak up the grease
you didn't even wear in the pan no no no
no when you if you had leftover bacon
she would put it I think so
I don't know yeah it would be on top of
bread I guess maybe to soak it up just
soak it up you know I I don't know I
never heard that but but then you got a
lopsided loaf you're gonna have an
uneven sandwich proportion now I don't
know if they're even all the time no I
don't think I don't think they're
counting to make sure they're even yeah
I I don't I don't remember any time I've
ever ended up with one end yeah always
yeah always always I feel like you have
an odd number a lot I don't think they
cut sandwich I don't think they cut bags
or loaves of bread I could be wrong but
the perfectly make a number of
sandwiches give that a GOOG
because I know they [__] you on the hot
dog buns or they used to that's just
good marketing they used to yeah you got
to buy two packs if you want to make
they don't do it anymore it's eight and
eight yeah there you go yeah
what do you got
20 to 24 uniform slices all bread
yeah
drywall in there too
and I'm in all loaves of bread that it
could it could differ if manufacturer to
manufacturer it's got to I wouldn't know
anyway because I always take an extra
piece make a to make a little yeah make
a little halfer yeah yeah yeah why I'm
making my Sammy
um yeah that's a good trick that I
remember that was somebody dropped out
on us when we were like I must have been
seven and I was like telling I was
telling other moms like yo throw a piece
of bread in there that'll really you
know it'll keep them fresh for the week
you know what I mean you gotta replace
the bread too because that like it gets
it's like it gets like a dry sponge real
hard let's throw it out though another
slice him hey touch I don't mean to be
telling tails at school but if you slide
a piece of Rye in there I think it's got
to be white It's gotta be something real
real porous you know what I mean I
assume you didn't mess with Pumpernickel
as a kid right now we were a strowman's
family through and through Rye at my
dad's from the bakery we get a fresh
fresh loafer rye and then he was that
Italian bread
uh that was divorced that [__] it was a
white just in the thing no no no no no
no no no uncut no no not not a like a
not like a baguette it was Italian no
though they're not baguettes they're
they're they're
no I'm not you're not we're not talking
about the same thing we're talking about
sliced white bread but it was like
called Italian style so Mare's Italian
oh yeah well that was banging was it
m-a-h-e-r something like that yeah that
was our local one that [__] was awesome
Bears Italian bread yeah it was just
white bread it was just white bread yeah
yeah it's exactly what it was mayor's
Italian bread mayor's premium Italian
bread delivers the same high quality
fresh baked bread and pre-sliced
store-bought convenience that's what we
were banging with back in the day you
know what else too they were a little
bigger a little bigger a little fluffier
yeah yeah let me go make a PB PB
sandwich on that long style
because the strowmans were squished
strowman breath stinks also too if she
if it was on sale she put it in the
freezer [__] break that out thaw that
out smelling like [__] crab legs or
whatever else was you know what deserves
a metal like a medal of honor is the
Aldi Split Top wheat at 89 cents a loaf
that kept me alive for about 10 years we
we had strowman split top wheat the
split top wheat some of it was with
butter
oh yeah they put butter in that crack
but that Aldi bread got butter in your
crack
sometimes
hit the Aldi grabs a split top of wheat
some off-brand PB and J that'll keep you
moving Aldi's wasn't around that's
that's weird that you had Aldi's
that was in my that was in my poor days
early 20s yeah oh they weren't around
yeah I know they were around but not
they weren't around that [__] wasn't
flying in Philly Audis were there I
think in Philly in 2000 so yeah oh 2000s
okay yeah I mean he wasn't like you know
this wasn't like the 80s I tried I keep
forgetting them you know what I mean
young whippersnapper you are
um all right let's see here that [__]
definitely would have flew in the 80s
now a German company oh yeah there's
yeah there was there were still some
tensions lying you know what I mean
there'd be guys out there with American
flags waving them you try to drop an
Audi all [__] on Washington Ave or
something you'd have problems you want
to sell me grapes You're Gonna Knock
that wall down
out of your goddamn mind yeah you think
I'm [__] donating to change your name
to Steve or something all right Franz
kick rocks yeah it ain't working
um all right let's see here this one's
from hoagiefest ten dollar homie never
had one red before is it garbage show
and a sports team street sign example
Steelers drives or parking for Eagles
fans only all others will be towed
hahaha that is a real Dirtbag thing but
it's a fun kissy thing in a bar you know
what I mean if you have any sort of real
street sign
even if it says something if it's like
real size and quality and color that's
cool I told you I'll give you that we
had a bunch of that [__] at the
fraternity house stop signs that were
stolen one of the one of the kids was
real tough guys huh one of the kids was
an engineer stole a traffic light we put
that in the in the in in the acid room
that was a good Friday night yeah it'll
get you sit there and watch that and
goof off
um yeah but anything like that that
shit's kind of that [__] is kind of
[__] cheese cheese-tastic you know I
always thought parking for Tom only or
whatever sure all right we've talked
about this I think but uh the license
plates on the wall
I thought I had one I still think that's
pretty cool it's not but in my head it's
like a bunch of different ways I
remember like looking at like a Florida
license plate a jersey one like whoa
yeah sweet I know steal all these cars
yeah I remember no that makes I guess
you guys I guess it's probably easy to
buy now but back in the day to get your
hands on different license plates you
gotta steal them no I'm sure you could
get them somehow oh you're stealing
license plates yeah no they were buying
those somewhere you think
yeah I mean I think it's still a license
plate that's like an actual that's not
just like Steel on a street sign really
stealing someone's Auto Tags
yeah that's that's like that's probably
State Property is that a felony I don't
think it's a felony oh my God it depends
on what you use it for it's a Class A
misdemeanor yeah class ah you don't say
yeah I mean I think I mean to do
misdemeanor but get that expunged yeah
but to do one sure but I mean if your
speed wheels are sealed if you're
stealing 40 to decorate your bar or
whatever that's like they'll Jam you up
if you're stealing a bunch of you're
just stealing license somebody comes in
it's their license plate what the [__]
gxq aren't going into long-term parking
with a screwdriver just decorating boys
what are you doing in the basement huh
treated looks like it's a home goods
yeah
okay
um that's all I would say
um all right this one's from the Kurt
May
shout out to the boys 10 shareholder
here looking to climb my way up that
corporate ladder there you go a real
go-getter shout out uh is it garbage to
take your family or significant other to
a used car lot sales promotion festival
for Saturday afternoon entertainment
with no plan on buying a car we've well
documented yeah nothing wrong with it I
don't know it's America right I've never
done it but back in the day
I well there was one on the bullet
there's a couple ones that would run
them we've talked they would run it on
local TV on like channels like an event
man they'd have like a gorilla out there
they'd have like a [__] some guy
would pull up dress like a dirt bike
circus yeah hey pal slip and slides a
slip and slide I don't care where it's
at free hot dogs are free diesel let's
do it and I tell you what you got an
Uncle Sam on a pair of stilts
look out
he didn't know what it was
you remember that the first time you saw
that I remember the first time I saw
somebody why was he always so tall I
don't know
it was just always a character they put
on still just to be over the crowd I
guess
so he can drop that savings onto you but
you know the you know the man he's got
to be above you to drop all those bucks
you know what I mean
hey Uncle Sam on stilts look out I want
you in a Nissan Altima yeah all that
[__] for no money down
which I resp I respect the local auto we
talked about that too the difference
between a dealer and a lot we were a lot
family my dad used cars all the time
from a guy who we knew my dad's favorite
show
was a local car infomercial he knew the
people this one's pretty hot where do
you see her oh wait she I'm sharing his
summer months she don't have all she's
not all bundled up eh love the July 4
sale did he big fella
he used to watch him all the time this
guy's pretty good I'm like it's a
[__] commercial what are you doing
yeah I respect though sure I mean I
would love to see them now they probably
don't do them as much now because
there's just better time to better ways
to spend that I don't know I catch him
when I hold my mom's they're still
poorly produced yeah it's like dude an
iPhone would look better than this what
am I doing probably paying thousands of
dollars too
yeah yeah but I guess people seem like
I'm gonna get down there to [__] Kia
dealership do the thing get in the money
Booth the whole nine yards which I
respect me too that's a good that's a
nice Saturday afternoon as a family okay
you get the kids hopes up that you're
buying a new car
I always thought we were getting a new
car like we're getting a new car it's
gonna be awesome nope we never put your
hot dog bun and shut up I never remember
pert like my mom
would just show up with the call we were
never involved in it oh we were heavily
involved no never it was a big deal I
remember we got our first Pontiac we
traded in my grandmother's uh Ford
Matador is what we were whipping around
and I remember I cried there you go
that's back to I remember I cried when
we pulled away that's different you're a
child because it was going to be there
it was going to be no who's gonna ride
in it it was gonna be there it was gonna
be all alone because we were whipping
around that news on the new Pontiac 600
yeah couldn't tell me nothing bucket
seats and a little [__] Steve Perry
on on the box let's go we always got
cars
I stepped out always had the same cars
for our whole life he just kind of kept
them until they disintegrated and then
and we get something else but like for
the majority of my life he had the same
two cars Ford Ranger and a big Suburban
um my mom then he would always parlay a
friend is getting rid of this it's a
good deal it's low miles it was garage
kept and he would buy that and then give
it to like my mom was just driving wild
cars that's smart though smart Sebring
convertible and she went to a
GM I don't know it was a bar why spend
the money with his thing yeah they never
bought it and she just recently got a
new car maybe three years ago for the
first time my parents just always leased
always new Maxima new Maxima new Maxima
new Maxima yeah and my dad my dad kept
his Nissan truck all through high school
I think I was rarely ever even in new
cars growing up like even like this is
the I mean I this is the first new car
I've owned was the Kia when I got that
two years ago my Uncle Mike used to get
a company any car every few years my dad
would get the new jeeps every time my
Uncle Mike that's a write-off every time
he got a new company car the whole
family would be over there it'd be like
a Wednesday night after after dinner
we're going to see Uncle Mike's Car we'd
be we'd act like we were on the lot for
that walking around looking under the
tires I swear to lots of where the fluid
goes something like some Oldsmobile with
wire wheels that just reminds me ac that
went down to about 12 degrees hook it in
there
eaters family friend of ours this is
shook a memory family friend of ours uh
uh had a kind of brand new white
Cadillac
brand spent like I remember I remember
because I remember the remember they
were they would start releasing them
before the year
like if it was 92 you could get a 93
type thing and he had an early one we
dude we went over
there was like 12 kids and he took us
all for rides it had a digital
speedometer I remember thinking I was in
The Matrix dude I'm like what the [__]
and he started whipping we were trying
to get to 100 in it
dude there was like 14 kids in it we're
like go go go we're flying down this
road at night and we're like get to I
remember being that ain't no Highway
either that's local oh local doing a
hundred remember a seat belt seat belts
no there's about 18 of us jumping around
in the back I was closing as I was I had
my hands over his eyes oh boy
shout out to Jared that's why I'll leave
it at shout out to Big Jared that's a
good piece of business brand new
Cadillac in Bucks County he's saying
[__] like yo they threw in his snake
skin boots for free
yeah it was all right man I had a man to
add the [__] repellent
jumping on the car like zombies that
might have been the that might have been
I can see that car if it's what I think
the white big body band a big body
[__] this thing was a boat he would
come did it have the did have the horns
on the front
who had that Texas dude no Dukes of
Hazzard Boss Hog had that I think he did
have the chain link uh license plate
perimeter
yeah flexing one of those chain link
yeah
you don't even need to have a license
plate in the front of the car yeah and
uh in PA they would just put them on
there that's only a New York thing to me
uh license plates on both sides oh
that's all right oh man
um where how do we even get there oh the
after the uh go to the used car
dealership yes yes
um
all right let's see here
um this is from Eric
uh I saw you guys in Providence with the
fam shout out too shout out to you um
what's the most garbage money sharing
app venmo cash app Zell I vote Facebook
AKA metapay they have that I guess
that's new to me I would say Zell is the
shittiest no Zell's used for business
Zell's like real really I had to
download it because someone's like we
had to pay or somebody's like I can pay
you in Zell and I was like I'm not
[__] down I'm a venmo man
cash app if I gotta but I'm venmo cash
app is the trashiest one because I think
when you got it you didn't have to have
a bank account yet no drug dealers take
Zell yeah no yeah don't go zelgo's on
the books really I don't know I think is
still a bit of a gray area
ah catch UPS [__] the Wild Wild West
little mail you cash if you want to take
it away go to cash out uh Facebook
Facebook pay on paper does seem trashy
but it might be it's one of the best
ones you use it I have in the past
instant money transfer no fee
I like no fees I'm a no fee kind of guy
for now but I do love it I'll pay for it
I like I need an instant transfer but
what are you buying something on
Marketplace you can do it for
Marketplace or you can use it like venmo
just send money to money I don't trust
[__] Facebook I mean they're getting
hacked left and right the government's
got their hand in there yeah the
Russians yeah next thing you know I'm
buying [__] I'm buying missiles in in
the Ukraine it's when I was freelancing
Buddy money's money now hey
I don't hate you gotta do what you got
to do to make ends meet the way I judge
that is what is what drug dealers
and uh
what drug dealers take cash app cash app
yeah that's still Lawless out there huh
okay because you don't have to
eat good to know bank accounts like I
don't have a bank account or a card
hooked up and I got money in there
somehow really I don't know what I don't
know how or what maybe they give you a
little money to start out hey here's 20.
don't tell nobody
[Music]
320. you know what I mean Daddio hey I
already have it uh yeah that's a pretty
good I think yeah but I do venmo I think
is the middle of the is the that's the
good one I think that's the they seem to
be on the up and up trust venmo PayPal
is like seems a little dial up Paypal
it's a little old yeah but it's good for
business they're like they focus on the
business aspect like the purchasing like
some of our merch goes through PayPal
and stuff they provide it through PayPal
it's like PayPal is more business I
think or like I'm gonna buy a car I'm
gonna PayPal you're not gonna venmo
someone 14 Grand no PayPal someone for
if you're buying like a car or whatever
no that's the more secure way to do it
I'm gonna be texting 14 Grand to
somebody I'm gonna log in all right I'm
gonna venmo them 14 and say oh my
secretary must have messed up then I'm
gonna dip that's like the big which I
respect I don't know if we've ever me
and you are a fan of the guy the guy I
think I mean you're the guy
who lied and almost bought the Islanders
100 yeah supposed to show up with a
check for like 15 million and showed up
with a check for 1500 and blamed the
second yeah
she missed five zeros bought him a
couple days guy Almost Got Away With It
Almost Got Away With It I respect I
respect and would have been fine if they
just would have gave it to him he would
have figured it out no I like that
because he had money because he would
have been able to to do something with
the capital of the team he would have
been able to have the money he lied
about once they gave him the team sure
which I guess he doesn't have that all
right yeah me too I start selling
tickets for a theme I don't know I have
a couple of bucks too
man that's a good 30 for 30. yeah it was
pretty good
um all right let's see this one's from
Jr
10 Pennsylvania investor shout out to
the good old Keystone State the
Commonwealth uh is it garbage to wash
your hair in the kitchen sink with dish
soap some mornings the Cabbage up top
needs an extra rinse yikes yikes dish
soap the birds do that my mom still
washes her hair
predominantly in the kitchen sink hmm
yeah she washes her hair dyes her hair
and [__] that's different that's you're
doing it you're doing a treatment or
something that I guess I used to love
that when I would get that for whatever
the bathroom sinks not deep enough you
can't get your Noggin in there
especially me I'm jammed up I got water
squirting all over the damn place unless
you got that little head disease got a
goddamn slip and slide in there yeah no
but I used to feel like I was at a salon
when my mom would do that wash my hair
in that thing pal around the warm with
the pull out the thing and the warm
water running over you
um there ain't nothing better than
getting your hair washed at the at the
at the barbershop
I mean I haven't done it and I think
Supercuts used to do it
sure I would always opt not to do it
though some broad with nails running
their fingers through your hair I would
dude I used to go to this place on the
Upper East Side when I worked up there
at that law firm and I'd go get my hair
cut it was expensive I had I mean it was
expensive for me at the time but now
just realizing that's what Manhattan
haircuts are sure it's like 45 bucks or
whatever Jesus yeah man dude Manhattan
haircuts are expensive yeah yeah dude
even in my neighborhood I think they're
35 20 at my spots yeah on the Burrows
talking I'm talking me I'm talking
Manhattan the Empire State of Mind but
he never sleeps never sleeps I go to a
fancy salon for the ladies yeah do a
little gossiping
um these two they were the best as a
little kid when you've got when for some
reason you'd go to the I'd get taken to
where my mom got her hair done I'd walk
in there like [__] Leonardo DiCaprio
oh my God
a couple of [__] Werther's Originals
hit me in the face a little off the top
honey yeah what's going on with you
broads I'm looking for a prom date if
anybody's interested Marcy that slug
husband of yours ever get a job what's
the deal
I know in eighth grade that'll spin you
around
uh oh man I know but I used to go to
this place it was these two Russian
chicks and it wasn't really a so now
that I'm looking back on it I don't know
if it's a full-blown Salon but they go
in there and they give you whiskey right
away you want some whiskey and that
first I was a little hesitant things are
going to dose me and steal my wallet use
my credit cards to buy art or something
I'm not falling for that [__] again
you wake up in a cargo container yeah
he's gonna cut still a little crooked
God damn it I shouldn't have tipped
there
No One's Gonna buy me now
[__] damage Goods I forgot a bad fade
here
you could have cleaned me up a little
bit I'm going I'm going out on the
market here this albanians are real
sticklers um
but they I mean they they weren't they
were too ugly broads too they weren't
even attractive but they would wash my
hair for about 45 minutes and I was
loving every minute of it it was all I
feel like the dog
it was good man couple shots they would
even let me up to take Zips of whiskey
and then put me back down feels pretty
good she's getting high and tights in a
Russian whorehouse it might have been
hey I didn't want to bring that up but
it really might have been one's cutting
your hair one stepping on your balls
a little freak got those binder clips on
my nipples
come on down to Hulk is cutting [__]
blow dry and yank the butt plugs out at
the same time
he'll be wet
um yeah it was a
uh not Nella looking bad one I put
secondary eyes on it
but like because you know like when you
go into a place and like the barber shop
has like or like the salon or whatever
has like the unit built into the wall
with the mirror like everything's in
this was just all like Furniture you
know what I mean like nothing was
connected to the wall get your hair cut
on a couch yeah it was like a nightstand
I'm sitting in a folding chair
my pants are off I don't know what's
happening
the police busted I'm just getting the
gun I swear yeah sure you are Punk
that's what they all say
[Laughter]
I remember my first barber shop I was
only always the only guy I was the only
person in there every time I went in and
I had to venmo them that's how I picked
them
Jesus I mean at least give me a [__]
handy or something I'm over here stiff
as a boat my first Barber Shop was Ron's
in Wilkes-Barre I think it was Ron's and
he was just old he was this older dude
cutting serious men's haircuts and every
once in a while something would happen
where I would get usually she'd be in
there with me Patty yeah of course but
she'd drop us off I think when we got a
little bit older I'm talking like 10
maybe 11. she'd run out to my aunts we'd
be in there and you know what they had
in there
a couple of eggs bodies pick up one of
them throw a Highlights magazine around
that while you threw that thing looking
at the highlights like this they knew
something was up I just can't find that
goddamn pencil shark
was that sure where is that crayon at
things I'd get to share with a stiffy
yeah punching through your nittly Lions
basketball shorts
foreign
shut up all right I'm losing my buzz
over here
yeah he won't have tall boys
is that fridge still cold what are we
doing here
um
all right let's hear this from from Kyle
is it garbage is shed a tear at any
point during the viewing of Joe Dirt
that's a good wholesome movie right
there I respect every goddamn second of
that film that's a great film maybe when
don't you think that Christopher
Walken's dead and then he comes back
yeah but only for like a half a second
huge per rack
he gets a Woody on the stretcher I just
watched it not too long ago that's right
um
um maybe at the end you know or
maybe when you finally see Brandy
pulling up on those Daisy Dukes on that
horse I'd shed a deer dude I had such a
[__] you never went on to do much
Naomi I think her name is she never I
Google her every time I watch the movie
she he was smoking yeah she was crazy
crazy attractive smoking okay to wanna
Kid Rock's great film performances
fantastic yeah yeah he was all right hey
what's up Ronnie
what are you doing Joe Dirt it's
actually pronounced deer Tay don't try
to church it up
um
yeah that was I mean it's a great movie
All In All I mean also white trash
handbook that movie is that's where like
I mean I hit you the other day with Van
Halen not van Hagar of course yeah of
course that's a straight joke and I hate
van Hagar
Sammy Hagar can kick rocks I was
introduced to just oh like that was too
young when that was like all that was
going down I just remember seeing him
with like the bleached hair and the Cabo
Wabo I just went like this guy seems
like he would annoy the [__] out of me
at a party like that's that's I was like
12. it seemed like this guy would be a
tough hang
I think my dad's looking for me get out
of here Hagar
do you work here dude
this is invite only billionaire that guy
sure
um well he was big on MTV I guess he was
trying to do a Resurgence or something
back when I was probably 10 or 12 or
whatever like he was they had this big
hit with ribs and they have this big hit
with him
um after David Lee Roth left uh right
now I think the name of the song was and
it was in a crystal Pepsi commercial yes
we might get hit for [__] plagiarism
you know I was [__] David Lee Roth
all day
the best [__] showman right there
there's a Winger man myself
shout out to Camp Winger
give me like rat round and round saw
them at the Pennsylvania state fair
which we should do this year by the way
we should get out of the racetrack at
the Pennsylvania state okay show you how
Kippy used to come up and bang There You
Go I mean he's another guy the meat guy
really give us the connect yeah look at
you get all these passes and free
tickets because we knew the guy that
supplied to me we always knew a guy the
right the Ryan's of the Sullivans all no
guys you got to will I be able to cure
my coaster fever there
uh I would not recognize getting any of
these rides dude this I mean it's in the
it's a mobile roller coaster I got
coaster fever brother I gotta get my fix
I don't even know if I don't even know
if it's still there to be honest with
you uh check Pennsylvania State Fair
Philadelphia race track used to be in
the parking lot of the racetrack already
on Street Road watch the ponies Trot go
out there and try to win a knife
did you ever go to the racetrack with
your family oh yeah no no the horse race
track oh yeah yeah okay my so my
stepmom's uh dad was big into Racers it
was a big horse big big Gambler big
horse racer guy
uh betting not like he wasn't even like
you know have a stable he wasn't a
trainer and uh the Pennsylvania state
fair stopped happening in 2004. damn
holy [__] holy Snake Eyes
ah just 20 years too late yeah I was
like see if they got any goldfish still
left
you know what happened all those what
happened all those giant stuffed animals
really that's what this says man I
wonder why someone got killed communism
probably if I have to guess
[__] you know Jesus Christ I got two
words for you Obama yeah thanks a lot
thanks a lot Bin Laden
Obama has two words
four years the first president two words
for you Obama
four years before his presidency still
blame it on him
yeah that sucks damn dude all that
shit's going away some of the great
that's where we fit the that's where we
fed the pot Billy big bubble gum and he
just sat there and cheweded and stared
at me and Pat for like an hour one of
the best laughs of my life man just a
pot belly big big chewing bazooka
it was all right that's a good piece of
business I mean dude I tell you me and
Pat laughed we ran out of quarters to
get the feed out I don't care how funny
you are animals chewing gum
nah all right let's see here this one's
from Sam Boney first time long time is
it garbage have a clothesline in your
backyard to dry laundry
now I feel that it's classy to have the
option because some things are nice on
the clothesline air dry if you're doing
it a winner though that's a tough look
hey that can't be your only form of
drying I'll say that when I was a kid
we had the clothesline in the backyard
sure and the sheets would go on there in
the summertime in the springtime sure
and respectable I tell you you're going
to bed at night smelling that fresh cut
grass was really happening asthma attack
it was really something else sure and
then for a while we had the we she that
the at the house we're in now she had
the
the one that went up and then came out
again look like an umbrella yeah yeah
exactly that's the one we had him
growing up yeah that's all right and
like ours was in like a concrete pad
with a hole and you would put 100 Post
in the hole like a yeah like a like a
patio umbrella type thing yeah and that
that got overtaken by wasps too it's got
a problem yeah those Hollow aluminum oh
yeah oh I remember those things would
get the hotty [__] I used to look down
there and just be like God no spiders
and this and that I wonder I assume the
pad still has to be in the backyard
actually now that I think about it what
the hole Yeah the hole with the concrete
sure it might just be grown over 100 I
haven't cut the grass in a long time
down there yeah we have a couple of
those floating around in the backyard
that has about 12 pounds of concrete in
it yeah a couple couple bags of Sakrete
like a German pill box there's nothing's
getting through that [__] uh-huh uh in
the city that's trashy yeah cause it's
like hanging out on something I mean but
on the Lower East Side yeah like 1920s
yeah
um yeah it's tough yeah I you
something's got to be dried I respect
that I'm gonna dry dry some of my teas
myself uh you know if I got the little
triangle the Accord drying rack you have
that in the house yeah you do uh-huh
yeah that's probably like nine bucks on
Amazon we went with that exclusively for
a while growing up really yeah I don't
know why they just don't dry right you
got a bacon collar okay yeah stinks it's
like working and also if you leave it
there too long then you have like a
crease in the T-shirt you go and look
like a like a folding chair that ain't
good
this one's from Arturo the choro ten
dollar homie never have on red let's go
um this one's a little kind of a little
longer is it garbage to offer to pay for
something as a favor get show them the
receipt so they know how much you paid
context my girl's Dad paid for new brake
pads and after he paid for them he gave
her the receipt so she doesn't forget
how much they cost them
that's if that's a face throw where I
come from I had a full-blown face throw
which I respect the face throw I had a
buddy in college real sharp guy came
from a real sharp family they did well
but they didn't baby the kids at all
they all had to work and all that kind
of stuff he used to send him the rest
not the receipt but he would send him a
copy of the check for tuition or
something yeah that I get man you're
cutting those checks are you know
depends where you're going and when you
were going 10 there were tens of
thousands of dollars yeah I respect that
used to make me feel like a piece of
[__] hey because I was blowing it oh
yeah yeah yeah bad student this kid was
an RA [__] Dean's List or honorable
whatever you had his dad used to send it
to him hey that's probably why he was a
good kid you could have used that you'd
snap into snap in the line a little bit
sure not doing all your drugs out there
in Seattle or whatever you were doing
playing sunny day for the with the boys
I wouldn't maybe you would have been an
R.A maybe you would have been on things
it wouldn't have mattered who might pay
my parents could have been [__] uh
General Patton yep I sell them you're
dumb yeah I still would have been
terrible at school
yeah I had undiagnosed ADHD when I was I
didn't know what was going on you
couldn't keep me for a second and they
didn't get me glasses until I was in
sixth grade I couldn't see a goddamn
thing and those were chocolates
see in the back and look cool
back here like Ray Charles anything the
teacher actually just go yeah that was
it
um yeah I had no shot
sure I get that just dumb when it comes
to that stuff we were big on that my my
family was big on that and always right
just dumb no oh smart Street Smart group
hey no I'm saying labeling one of the
family members he's just dumb
and let me never say that
you would just say he just don't get it
yeah
but yeah yeah but he's making that
thieves boy he just don't get it yeah
yeah Harry's son he just don't get it
that was kind of my family's approach to
me until you still don't get it until
late in high school I think they tried
they made an effort I think I was over
at Sylvan Learning Center for like one
time working painting the walls or
something
okay get this kid doing manually yeah it
was over there for something I was like
I'm not going back there the guy [__]
sucked and then
um in college when I got diagnosed with
you know add or whatever it was uh it
was just from Ritalin that was just drug
seeking Behavior yeah I mean they gave
it to me and I did it all one weekend at
Penn State and then they never put me
back on it but they made me see like I
had to go to like a therapist for a
little while for like you know learn for
learning disabilities or whatever but by
then it was
it was too late it's out the door yeah
uh no we would get the face throw of the
amount of money spent on whatever and
that number was always rounded up
if something cost
412 dollars it's 500 that was 500 bucks
coming right down your skull I just
spent 500 in the goddamn Road
just something getting launched at you
me and the worst was if it wasn't
directly to you it was to somebody else
I guess my mom my dad going out I just
gave him the gate 800 bucks for the
[__] whatever or whatever it was 6.95
yeah [__] you say yeah Jam me up real
sweet it cut down a gravy train
foreign
once he got that I was playing both ends
against the middle of trying to get
stuff as like that he got pinched oh
yeah I didn't know that yeah I worked
until about
sixth or seventh grade yeah I remember
you got the the BB gun the mini BB gun
the mini bike and then he yeah maybe
that's when times got a little tough to
come to think of it
so when the phone call started
it's when we got jammed up he gives you
his phone hey I'm not here that was a
big thing I ain't here
who's going who's calling you at
midnight I I don't know who it is
tell them I'm not working you got to
stay up Amanda phone it's like a call
center oh God that goddamn anytime I
hear you're answering the phone is Jerry
it is Jerry that's why I can't answer a
phone I can't hear a phone it's like
PTSD of people looking for money even
even with me I mean with EZPass just
called me but he has like what an hour
that's crazy they called you for 25
bucks it might be more than 25.
well why wouldn't it work I don't know
that ain't my Pro here's the story this
is more hard feelings we'll get into it
I have Easy Pass I'm doing all right and
you haven't put up there no there you go
and I put it on the dashboard and
sometimes if I'm banging a hard left she
slides around on me and I can't find her
but it's in the car my defense is it's
in the car
also all right here's the thing if they
this is Dirtbag logic I I pay for this I
pay for the service whatever
they bill me
when I go through it if it doesn't pick
up they should go into their system to
be like hey
does this license plate have an active
tag and is paid up they don't they just
mail me a bill so now it's all me to
write a [__] check or go online and
pay something an Easy Pass mail today
not the state of Easy Pass
me
and then there's some local
municipalities sniffing around for cash
or okay Lower Makefield never going back
there he had no [__] I don't even know
where you are I remember we drove back
from Virginia one time me and my buddy
we didn't have money for the for the
tolls and we did we just fill out
paperwork that burned that car a couple
years later torch it under the gwb let's
get out of here yeah that's all that's
all kooky patooki to me
um I don't probably get to the point
where I end up owing 300 bucks and I get
mad and just pay it there you go but I'm
not getting I mean 25 I'll go to the
goddamn mattresses I ain't got nothing
better to do yeah I gotta I go it's 25
bucks your Easy Pass
do the math to start Google my license
plate it's in a system I got a thing
from uh some collection agency in
Chicago Chicago it's like Sterling and
Sterling or something like that oh
that's that's a law firm nah I am into
my phone I could look it's it's a
collection agency I looked it up for 200
bucks from Mount Sinai I'm in there all
the time say something about me on his
shoulder besides you [__] you're
turning me in for 200. yeah how much
money I [__] put in your pocket over
the last couple of years we're on a test
and the doctor's visits and this and
that and the other thing you're [__]
ratting me up to somebody outside the
family yeah and I got them trying to
call me for 200 bucks get the fight
collection it should be it's got to be
in the thousands
can't be hitting somebody up for 45
bucks 25 bucks 25 bucks easy pass the
bridge is 16 alone they get in and out
of New York they're breaking my stones
for 25 bucks you're in the hospital
going I don't tell anybody about the bad
[__] you tell me yeah no [__] keep my
mouth shut
I know that IV's just ginger ale you
think I'm [__] stupid
[Laughter]
[__] bastards
crazy well we gotta wrap it up gang gang
we love you to death love Yas come see
us on the road there sign up for the
patreon yeah we're all over the road the
tickets are moving fast some cities by
the time this comes out might be gone uh
so get them don't snooze on that because
they're going quick and we'll be adding
the second leg in the third leg Yeah
Yeah if your City's not on there we're
coming to see you baby oh yeah stay
trashy tour 2023 let's go peace peace